there is a new player tonight hard to
believe but there is in the Democratic
presidential sweepstakes billionaire
activist Tom Steyer says he will fight
what he calls the hostile corporate
takeover of our democracy this comes as
the front-runner puts his financial
records in the spotlight correspondent
Peter Doocy has specifics tonight from
the hill the former vice president calls
himself middle class Joe when Washington
that's not meant as a compliment but
since leaving office middle-class Joe
has been making top dollar book payments
and speaking engagements added up to
eight ten and a half million dollar
raise between 2016 and 2017 and more
money for the Biden's meant more money
for charity nine point two percent of
his salary in 2017 a million dollars
more than the one and a half percent of
his salary in 2016 the 76 year old
hasn't liked gold first place yet but
the Democratic field just won't shrink
because the day after one dropped out
another jumped in my name is Tom Steyer
I'm running for president
the billionaire steyr teased a run
earlier this year and the platform was
to impeach I'm strengthening my
commitment to need to impeach but the
word impeachment was missing from Stiers
announcement video I think what people
believe is that the system has left them
I think people believe that the
corporation's have bought the democracy
that the politicians don't care about or
respect them the Trump campaign
responded quote it doesn't say much for
the whole Democrat field that the number
one Democrat donor took a look around
and decided that there's no one he can
support and Democrats sound just as
excited Elizabeth Warren tweeted quote
the Democratic primary should not be
decided by billionaires Bernie Sanders
shares the sentiment and is also
discounting Joe Biden's recent apology
for past remarks about civility with
segregationists Joe has talked about his
early days in the Senate when things was
civil but underneath that so-called
civility that was an incredible
oppression and ugliness and attacks
against the african-american community
but the Biden's don't believe much
damage has been done
can people know Joe Biden they know his
values they know what he stands for and
they didn't buy it something else the
American people know about Joe Biden he
was once the poorest man in the Senate
it's something he talks about on a
campaign trail all the time so now we
wait to see if he keeps talking about it
after supporters and opponents have seen
his eight figure income Brett produced
up on Capitol Hill Peter thanks